monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs dans chacun des
territoires que vous représentez depuis
trois semaines des groupes de français
ayant enfilé un gilet jaune parfois des
groupes très restreint parfois du groupe
plus large organise des barrages
filtrants ouvre des péages occupent des
ronds-points ou des zones commerciales
ces actions se déroulent en général dans
le calme un calme qui contraste avec
l'extrême violence que nous avons
connues samedi dernier à paris et dans
de nombreuses villes à toulouse à
marseille où puy en velay où le
président de la république s'est rendu
mardi
j'aurais pu également citer l'île de la
réunion où annick girardin s'est rendu
la semaine dernière pour échanger avec
les manifestants les élus et apporter
des réponses aux questions et aux
colères qui était formulée vous êtes où
vous avez été des élus locaux
moi aussi cette colère vous ne découvrez
pas moi non plus nous l'avons senti
monter
année après année élection après
élection qu'elle se formule parfois par
d abstention massive ou qu'elle se
formulent d'autrefois par des coups de
semonce
contrairement à quelques autres je ne
cherche pas à désigner les coupables de
cette colère mais je constate qu'elle
vient de loin qu'elle a longtemps était
muette et que si elle a été muette c'est
parce que longtemps elle a été tu
par pudeur par fierté parfois car se
mettre en colère et dénoncer quelque
chose que l'on subit c'est parfois vécue
est perçu comme quelque chose qui ne
serait pas à la hauteur
certains ont reconnu avec beaucoup de
sagesse et d'honnêteté que cette colère
venaient de loin je veux les en
remercier pas en mon nom propre bien
entendu mais au nom de ceux qui loin des
surenchères recherche sans renier bien
évidemment leur conviction que les deux
sont possibles une issue républicaine à
une crise dont la violence a surpris
tout le monde
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de citer et je
leur fais bien volontiers dans cet
hémicycle le nom est l'oeuvre de marc
bloch et je note que d'enceinte ses plus
célèbres ouvrages
il évoque l'importance de la lucidité
lucidité évoqué comme un exercice
permanent qui implique d'être constant
quand on croit que ce que l'on fait est
juste et d'avoir le courage de faire
autrement quand quelque chose ne
fonctionne pas tous les maires tous les
présidents d'exécutifs locaux l'ont vécu
au moins une fois
c'est à cet exercice que nous nous
sommes attelés
un exercice qui se traduit de trois
manières différentes
lucidité d'abord sur la situation
d'extrême tension que traverse notre
pays
des tensions qui nous ont conduits à la
conclusion qu'aucune taxe ne méritait de
mettre en danger la paix civile
comme je les dis hier à l'assemblée
nationale nous avons donc décidé avec le
président de la république de renoncer
aux mesures fiscales concernant le prix
des carburants et les prix de l'énergie
qui devait entrer en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2019
le sénat ayant voté la suppression de
ces taxes dans le projet de loi de
finances 2010 9 elles ne seront pas
réintroduites du civic est ensuite
lucidité ensuite sur la méthode
d'autres méthodes ça n'est jamais que le
moyen qui permet d'atteindre le but
qu'on s'est fixés c'est une méthode qui
s'adapte à une situation qui par nature
n'est jamais figé parce que certains
problèmes demandent des solutions
rapides et que d'autres exigent des
concertations plus large
c'est l'objectif du débat que le
président de la république m'a demandé
de conduire un débat qui vise à répondre
à trois questions concrètes
la première concerne le rythme les
modalités le calendrier de la transition
écologique qui demeure nous le savons
tous pour notre pays pour nos
territoires
je pense en particulier à nos
territoires ultramarins mais pour tous
les territoires de la france pour notre
écho de boue pour notre agriculture pour
notre pouvoir d'achat
un horizon qui n'est ni négligeable li
négociable j'ai proposé une première
série de mesures d'accompagnement
laquelle venait s'ajouter à des mesures
déjà existantes d'accompagnement de
cette transition
ces mesures sont massives par leur
montant est long à bien des égards
prouver une partie de leur efficacité
en tout cas auprès d'une partie de la
population si j'en juge par la
consommation par le recours massif et
même supérieur à celui qui avait été
initialement envisagé un des dispositifs
comme par exemple la prime à la
conversion automobile elles ont prouvé
donc partie de leur efficacité
mais elles ne répondent pas si j'en
crois les manifestants à la totalité des
besoins exprimés par les français
le débat doit donc permettre de les
compléter avec les français avec les
professionnels avec les élus avec tous
ceux qui peuvent exprimer le besoin
précis et travailler aux réponses
adaptées
la deuxième question concerne les
trajets domicile travail des trajets qui
ponctionnent une part importante des
salaires des revenus en général un peu
comme l'ont dit certains comme un impôt
cassé sur le travail ses charges et
muriel pénicaud
jacqueline gourault et elisabeth bornes
de conduire une concertation avec les
organisations syndicales et avec les
élus pour nous aider à trouver des
solutions rapides et concrètes qui
s'adapte aux spécificités de leur
territoire un certain nombre de ces
consultations avaient été engagées dans
le cadre de la préparation de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités et j'observe
que beaucoup d'associations d'élus
avaient salué ce travail de concertation
mais il peut être approfondies
là encore pour trouver territoire par
territoire indépendamment des
dispositifs institutionnels le cas
échéant les solutions adaptées aux
besoins exprimés par nos concitoyens
enfin dernière question la fiscalité la
dépense publique
les français qui porte un gilet jaune
l'andi ils veulent moins d'impôts moins
de taxes et savoir à quoi ces impôts et
taxes servent et c'est bien légitime
nous devons donc ouvrir un débat le
débat il a lieu évidemment et
heureusement c'est le sens même de la
démocratie et du contrôle parlementaire
chaque année dans les deux assemblées
mais reconnaissons ensemble mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que la
technicité de ce débat sa qualité à
certains égards mais sa grande
technicité rend parfois difficile la
lecture les enjeux de l'utilisation de
telles ou telles enveloppes
la réalité où les perspectives de telle
ou telle recette
nous devons donc ouvrir un débat qui
permette de ramener de la clarté de la
transparence dans une question dont nous
savons tous qu'elle est très passionnel
en france une question passionnelle que
nous devons aborder dans le calme sans
pour autant transiger sur l'ambition je
me fixe de règles en la matière d'abord
que ce débat ne crée pas de nouvelles
taxes et qu'ils ne viennent pas creuser
ou augmenter encore la dette
nous voulons baisser les impôts très
bien alors regardons l'ensemble du sujet
de la dépense des recettes et de cette
dette qui a crû de façon très
significative en france depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années
soyons vigiles vigilant vigilant à ce
que nous ne l'ayons pas à nos enfants
des taxes futur des dettes qui viendront
grève et leur pouvoir d'achat
et soyons vigilants à ce que la maîtrise
de la dépense publique préserve les
territoires et les français qui en ont
le plus besoin
enfin je souhaite que ce débat puisse
aussi même si là encore pour beaucoup de
français cela semble clair je souhaite
que ce débat puisse nous permettre de
prendre conscience de la chance dont
nous disposons de pouvoir bénéficier de
services publics de qualité des services
qui ailleurs peuvent parfois coûter très
cher et très cher directement nous
payons des impôts qui sont effectivement
très élevé en france
mais ce sont aussi grâce à ses impôts
que nous pouvons consacrer en moyenne
6200 euros par an à chaque élève
scolarisé à l'école primaire jules 1500
euros à chaque collégien français
12000 euros pour chaque lycéen en lycée
professionnel des sommes importantes qui
sont à la charge de l'état ou des
collectivités territoriales et qui
relèvent du paiement par les français de
l'impôt et des taxes
ce débat il doit être nationale et doit
être également territoriale au plus près
des français
il doit être institutionnelle puisque
nous pouvons nous appuyer et c'est tant
mieux sur des associations des
institutions qui ont été créés pour
faire vivre le débat public au premier
rang desquels bien entendu les deux
assemblées
mais au-delà de ces deux assemblées
parlementaires le conseil économique
social et environnemental les
institutions régionales qui existent en
la matière mais il doit être aussi ce
débat informel direct afin que chacun
sache qu'il pourra y prendre part et
qu'il pourra être entendue je souhaite
que les élus leur association ils
prennent toute leur place que les
français puissent y contribuer qu'on y
parle aussi peut-être de toutes ces
dépenses contraintes qui sans être
juridiquement ni des impôts ni des taxes
pèse au fond au moins autant sur ce qui
reste à la fin du mois il est impératif
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
les maires prennent toute leur part dans
ce débat et permettez moi de profiter de
cette tribune pour saluer et remercier
ceux d'entre eux qui ont relayé notre
message d'apaisement remercié
l'association des maires d'ile-de-france
qui a proposé d'ouvrir des cahiers à
destination de ceux des français qui
souhaitent s'exprimer directement
remercier aussi les maires ruraux qui
organise ce samedi une journée mairie
ouverte pour dialoguer pour moi la vraie
démocratie directe celle qui permet
d'allier la proximité la légitimité
c'est bien celle-là les maires sont
d'ailleurs une fois encore en première
ligne sur le terrain pour
appelé au calme et répondre à la colère
certains nous ont demandé des effectifs
policiers supplémentaires en prévision
de samedi prochain
nous travaillons activement avec ce qui
exprime ses besoins pour pouvoir y
répondre dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
cette lucidité nous a conduits à
rechercher l'apaisement
elle nous conduit aussi à continuer à
avancer a continué à apporter tenter
d'apporter des réponses très concrètes
sur mesure pas toujours très
spectaculaire mais durable à nos
territoires des territoires dont nous
savons tous qu'ils n'ont ni les mêmes
atouts ni les mêmes besoins
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à travailler
avec les élus les élus alsaciens pour
essayer d'imaginer avec eux une
structuration une évolution permettant
de prendre en compte leur inspiration
mais les aspirations également légitimes
des autres élus de la région grand est
c'est ce qui nous a permis de travailler
avec les élus notamment du département
des ardennes à la constitution et à la
construction d'un pacte permettant là
encore de trouver des solutions
concrètes et des moyens pour faire
évoluer la situation dans le bon sens
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à poursuivre
l'initiative qui avait été pris dans le
bassin minier en y apportant des
financements les financements qui avait
été évoquée de façon à là encore définir
sur mesure sur mesure les besoins des
territoires et la réponse de l'état
c'est ce qui sera inscrit dans le pacte
qui liera l'état à la région bretagne et
dans celui qui est en discussion avec
que pays de la loire
c'est aussi la raison du déploiement de
la police de sécurité du quotidien c'est
aussi dans le domaine du raccordement
haut débit dont nous savons tous et dont
nous aidons nous discutons souvent de la
nécessité et de l'urgence qui s'y
attachent le plan d'équipement qui voit
que qui fait que 2800 pylônes depuis
janvier dernier ont reçu les équipements
nécessaires pour la 4g avec vous le
savez un changement de logique dans la
relation entre l'état et les opérateurs
qui nous permet d'envisager un
équipement plus rapide et plus complet
du territoire par rapport à ce qui était
initialement prévu
c'est dans le domaine de la santé la
suppression du numerus clausus enfin
dans le temps de faire en sorte que le
nombre de médecins augmente et les 1500
jeunes médecins qui depuis mai 2010 sept
ont décidé de s'installer dans des zones
fragiles c'est le remboursement puis
septembre 2018 de la téléconsultation
aucun de ces instruments à eux seuls est
une réponse à des problèmes très vaste
et très ancien mais il nous paraît que
ces instruments constituent des éléments
de réponse et qu'il faut les évoquer
c'est le déploiement du plan action
coeur de ville qui consacre 5 milliards
d'euros à la revitalisation des centres
de 222 villes petites et moyennes
c'est aussi la réorientation de nos
investissements des tgv vers les
déplacements du quotidien une
réorientation qui est forcément lente et
qui est toujours délicate qui n'est
jamais insensible notamment pour les
territoires qui attendent la
construction de ces lignes à grande
vitesse mais qui est nécessaire si nous
voulons pouvoir entretenir dans de
meilleures conditions les
infrastructures qu utilisent des
millions de passagers si nous voulons
essayer de désengorger les métropoles
grâce aux rails et notamment rails de
proximité si nous voulons désenclaver
les villes où les territoires ruraux
je pense à la rn 164 en centre-bretagne
promise dans le général de gaulle je
vois c'est la rn 122 à aurillac
qu'edouard balladur je crois s'était
engagé à construire c'est la rn88 du
puy-en-velay vers mende et rodez
on pourrait citer la rn2 entre hirson et
maubeuge la rn 21 entre vers périgueux
on pourrait citer aussi me semble-t-il
l'autoroute vers castres depuis toulouse
c'est enfin la future loi d'orientation
sur les mobilités que vous allez
examiner
cette lucidité doit nous conduire à
continuer de mieux rémunérer le travail
parce que derrière la question du
pouvoir d'achat
il y à celle de la rémunération du
travail en france qui durant de
nombreuses années n'a pas assez
augmenter ou a été grevé par des
évolutions notamment des évolutions
d'impôt depuis le mois d'octobre
des millions de salariés ont bénéficié
d'une hausse certes toujours moins
importante que celle qu'on espérait mais
néanmoins réelle de leur salaire net dès
le mois de janvier 2019 le smic
augmentera de 1,8 pour cent et sur un an
grâce à l'action conjuguée de cette
indexation de la baisse des cotisations
sociales et de la prime d'activité la
hausse est de l'ordre de 3% par rapport
au 1er janvier 2018
la hausse de la prime des activités que
nous avons décidé pour avril 2019
amplifiera encore cet effet et je suis
prêt à examiner toutes les mesures qui
permettraient d'augmenter les
rémunérations au niveau du smic sans
pénaliser excessivement la compétitivité
de nos entreprises et les salariés
pourront encore gagner plus grâce à la
suppression des cotisations sociales sur
les heures supplémentaires
vous aurez enfin mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs l'occasion d'acter dans le
cadre du projet de loi pacte le
développement massif de l'épargné
salariale de l'intéressement et de
l'actionnariat salarié
nous continuerons à nous battre pour
l'égalité des chances parce que la
colère qui s'exprime concerne évidemment
les fins de mois et même souvent les
milieux de moi mais elle concerne aussi
l'avenir celui d'enfants de millions de
familles qui ont le sentiment de ne pas
avoir les mêmes chances que les autres
de réussir c'est le sens des mesures de
dédoublement des classes dans les
réseaux et paieraient plus dont les
retours formulés par les élus les
enseignants les parents sont positifs
c'est le sens aussi du dispositif de
voir fait au collège de la scolarisation
qui sera évoquée prochainement dès l'âge
de 3 ans et qui est une très belle
mesure républicaine parce que l'art
isation obligatoire d'attenté
c'est le sens de la réforme de
l'apprentissage
d'eau chacun sait qu'il permet de
s'insérer avec plus de facilité dans le
monde du travail le sens de la refonte
de notre système de formation
professionnelle le sens de
l'investissement massif dans les
compétences que nous souhaitons réaliser
cette lucidité nous oblige à continuer
de réduire la dépense publique dans
notre pays
justement pour pouvoir baisser les
impôts nous avons vu combien ces deux
baisses parce qu'elles sont liées sont
urgentes en 2017
la france a réduit ses déficits il
continuera à le faire
elle maîtrise la hausse de la dépense
publique de l'état
grâce à l'engagement des élus elles
maîtrisent aussi la hausse de la dépense
publique locale et grâce à nos efforts
continus ceux de nos prédécesseurs et
ceux de la majorité actuelle nous allons
pouvoir voter un budget de l'associé de
la sécurité sociale l équilibre ces
tendances encourageantes sont le fruit
d'efforts collectifs en vérité - celle
de majorités successives que des
français passé présent nationaux et
locaux
depuis le mois d'octobre des millions de
contribuables ont bénéficié d'une baisse
de 30% de leur taxe d'habitation une
taxe que beaucoup d'entre nous disait à
juste titre injuste une taxe que
beaucoup d'entre nous dénoncé depuis des
années et que nous allons supprimer par
tranches successives en compensant comme
c'est bien naturel et comme c'est
surtout bien constitutionnel à leurs
prêts pour les collectivités la charge
nous avons choisi aussi de réduire et de
simplifier la fiscalité sur le capital
parce qu'il s'agissait d'un engagement
pris au moment de la campagne
présidentielle puis de la campagne
législative devant les français parce
que nos entreprises ont besoin de
capital pour se développer parce que
notre pays a besoin d'investisseurs
nationaux et étrangers
c'est un choix de stratégie économique
totalement annoncé
est totalement assumé ce soit ce choix
je les dis hier nous sommes prêts à
l'évaluer nous n'avons pas peur de ce
débat nous pensons qu'il est nécessaire
et nous croyons même qu'il permettra de
documenter de démontrer le bien fondé de
ce choix enfin cette lucidité nous
conduit à poursuivre ce combat
indispensable en faveur en faveur de
solidarité bien réel ce ne sont pas
forcément les mesures dont on parle le
plus et pourtant nous savons que ce sont
souvent celles qui changent la vie dans
les faits la revalorisation de tous les
minima sociaux bien entendu la mise en
place du tiers payant pour le complément
de mode de garde au 1er janvier 2019
l'offre de petits déjeuners dans les
zones redd plus les repas à un euro dans
les comptes dans les cantines des
communes rurales qui ne disposait pas ou
ne pouvait pas offrir ce service
la possibilité pour tous les français à
partir de 2019 et de manière progressive
de bénéficier d'une prise en charge à
100% de leurs lunettes de leurs frais
dentaires ou de leur prothèse auditive
ses dépenses
ce sont souvent des dépenses très lourde
elle ne pèseront plus sur le pouvoir
d'achat
là où la lucidité commandes de faire
différemment la même lucidité commandes
de poursuivre les grandes
transformations parce que toutes ces
transformations apporte une réponse
parfois de cours parfois de moyens
parfois de long terme aux préoccupations
qui s'extrait avant que le débat ne
s'engage je voudrais dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs un mot des
violences que nous avons déploré et de
la sécurisation des probables
manifestation de samedi prochain
mes premiers mots seront d'abord pour
nos forces de l'ordre ces hommes ces
femmes ont été les victimes d'un
incroyable déchaînement de violence dont
bien souvent le but était d'attaquer de
blessés parfois même de tuer ses hommes
ces femmes ne sont pas simplement des
représentants de la république ne
serait-il que des représentants de la
république ce serait déjà une immense
fierté
ils ont été samedi gardien de la
république les incarnations de la
république
les défenseurs de la république je veux
leur dire en mon nom propre et au nom de
l'ensemble dû gouvernement et je crois
au nom de l'ensemble de la nation ma
reconnaissance
mon admiration face à leur sang froid
face à leur professionnalisme
permettez moi de remercier également
l'administration et les services
judiciaires qui se sont mobilisés pour
apporter des réponses pénales rapides et
fermes aux délits commis samedi dernier
je voudrais aussi mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs redire mon dégoût mon
dégoût en découvrant les images du
saccage de l'arc de triomphe ce dégoût
des millions de français l'ont ressentie
dans leur chair tout comme il condamne
les menaces ou les agressions contre les
représentants de la nation
élus ou fonctionnaires nous en
retrouverons les auteurs ils seront
traduits en justice
et j'espère mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qu'ils seront sévèrement punis
depuis le début des contestations nous
n'avons jamais interdit de rassemblement
cela étant les événements de samedi
dernier doivent nous conduire à faire
preuve de la plus grande prudence et de
la plus grande détermination
c'est pourquoi le ministre de
l'intérieur a invité celles et ceux qui
envisageaient de se rendre à paris
samedi prochain pour manifester à ne pas
le faire il ne s'agit pas d'interdire de
s'exprimer mais bien d'éviter qu'il soit
pris au piège d'une certaine façon que
leur tendent les casseurs pour y faire
face le gouvernement va mobiliser des
moyens exceptionnels qui s'ajouteront
aux 65 mille forces de sécurité qui
seront déployés dans toute la france
nous continuerons à interpeller à
traduire en justice toute personne prise
en flagrant délit de violence ou de
dégradations nous continuerons à faire
preuve de la plus grande fermeté nous
nous battrons contre la haine et contre
la violence qui s'exprime dans une
incroyable violence
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs dans
la situation à laquelle nous faisons
face le devoir de lucidité s'impose à
tous
le devoir de responsabilité également
aux élus aux membres du gouvernement aux
élus locaux aux responsables des
formations politiques aux commentateurs
aux éditorialistes aux citoyens à tous
il s'impose à tous parce que la liberté
va toujours de pair avec la
responsabilité
je voudrais pour en conclure profité de
cette tribune pour saluer tous ceux qui
ont lancé ou relayer cet appel au calme
les organisations syndicales des
associations des élus nationaux quelles
que soient les formations politiques
dont ils sont membres
et quelle que soit la vision ou la
position qu'il puisse avoir
face au gouvernement ils ont dit ils ont
dit que leur responsabilité était
d'appeler au calme et à ne pas
manifester samedi
cette responsabilité les honore et je
voudrais dire combien elle les grandit
en france dans cet hémicycle
comme dans toutes les rues c'est la
république qui doit avoir toujours le
dernier mot elle est une autre chose
notre chose commune et puisque nous
l'aimons nous devons la préserver
c'est vous remercie merci monsieur le
premier
[Applaudissements]